my family left korea when i was seven
years old
and i never really took the time to
learn
its history and culture until a few
years
[Music]
you probably know of korea as two
different countries
as north and south korea
but relative to its overall history
which begins as
early as 700 bc this
is a fairly recent occurrence and
actually for much of its history it's
been attacked and controlled by foreign
forces
and has had to constantly fight for
independence
and today i'm going to be sharing a
project that i did in my fourth year of
architecture school
that's taught me a bit about the painful
history of korea
and has made me think a little deeper
about the meaning of a shared identity
as well as the role of architecture in
addressing
complex cultural and political conflicts
in 1910 korea was invaded
and colonized by japan until 1945 when
japan was defeated by the allied forces
in the second world war
korea was liberated from japanese rule
but the us and the soviet union both
wanted
a piece of korea so they decided that
the country will be split in half
the soviets occupying the north and the
americans occupying the south
they simply drew a line across the map
and
decided to divide the country along the
38th parallel
which has now become the dmz of course
the koreans didn't get a say in any of
this
the soviets helped elect a communist
guerrilla leader
into office and the americans helped a
u.s educated democratic leader
into office since then both the
north and south desperately wanted a
united korea
but of course under their own rule and
political regime
and there was a lot of tension between
the two sides
in 1953 the north korean leader tried to
overthrow the south korean government in
an attempt to unify the two countries
which led to the korean war pitting
koreans
against koreans since then the two
countries have been
in a perpetual state of war forcing
young korean men in their
20s into mandatory military service for
18 months leaving a pretty big gap
in its economy and social structure if
you're a fan of korean dramas
this also sometimes serves as a
convenient resolution to the plot
so while the two countries still use the
same language
they've diverged on pretty much all
aspects including
political ideology culture and economy
for most south koreans reunification is
an unrealistic impractical
and even a contentious idea the vast
majority of the south korean population
today
especially the younger generation oppose
reunification
just until the late 90s there was around
80
support from south koreans for
reunification
but a poll in 2011 showed that the
number had been reduced
to 56 percent
higher
people on my grandparents generation
however
still have long lost family members on
the other side of the border
this is a footage from a rare reunion in
2018 that was granted by the north
korean government
the families were reunited after seven
years
and were given 11 hours together over
the time span of three days to see each
other
with no repeat visits allowed the
families were selected based on a
lottery
and there are 56 000 koreans on the
waiting list to be picked for visits
like this
every year around 3 000 of these people
die
reducing the number of families waiting
to be reunited
this event was the result of a
government-led process towards
reunification
which was started in 2000 in the june
15th
north south joint declaration where both
governments agreed to promote
reunification
in their respective countries i also
remember pretty clearly as a kid in
elementary school
learning about our friendly neighbors in
the north
and learning songs about reunification
[Music]
practical and economic concerns aside in
instances when the two koreans meet
it's been shown over and over again that
it's an
unexplainable emotional experience
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
reunification still remains a very lofty
goal
something on the very far horizon for
both nations
one of the efforts to strengthen the
north-south relations was the push to
create
industrial and economic ties by
establishing areas like the kesang
industrial park
which would allow south korean companies
to employ cheap labor
in north korea while creating jobs and
income for the north korean economy two
years after its opening the number of
north korean staff
hit 10 000 workers a year after it
doubled and in 2012
it reached over 50 000.
the accumulated earnings from goods
produced at the complex rose from some
100 million us dollars in 2007
to 2 billion in 2013.
the park is located 10 kilometers north
of the dmz
and it's the only direct road and rail
access between north and south korea
the dmz the korean demilitarized
zone is an incredibly unique condition
of its own it's been a four kilometer
buffer between
north and south korea since the korean
war in 1953
and this restricted land hasn't been
altered by human hands for the past
70 years and as a result
has created a natural paradise for an
incredibly diverse range of animal
and plant species that have pretty much
vanished in
many other parts of the world
[Music]
however the barbed wire fence that runs
along the dmz is impenetrable
not only for people but also for animals
and this has created a fragmented
landscape between the two
mega ecosystems limiting the possibility
of
further growth when connected the
ecosystem has
huge environmental possibilities and as
a whole
could become the starting point for a
natural wildlife corridor extending to
the rest of asia
in 2014 during my fourth year studio we
were given a project brief
which was to create a border crossing
between any two countries
i decided on the border between north
and south korea
not just for personal reasons but for
the complex social economic and
environmental conditions
based on my research i wanted to create
a commercial border crossing
on the existing road to the industrial
region
but at the same time wanted to address
the separation
of the wildlife corridor by the barbed
wire fence
the separation of the wildlife corridor
by the road connecting the industrial
regions
by also introducing an animal crossing
this animal crossing would be
structurally supported by
public observation towers on either
sides of the border
as the two buildings hold up and connect
the broken wildlife
corridors in four directions it would
first of all provide a public attraction
that would
allow us to admire the wildlife
let us witness the economic activity
that's happening
and at the same time provide a place
where we can gaze over to the other side
of the border
where in the least it could be the
beginning of
some kind of kindred emotions
this actually isn't my typical process
for designing a building but
on this project there was a descriptive
word that
kept coming to my mind as i mulled over
the conditions
in korean you would call this
loosely translating into tension
tension merriam-webster describes as
state of latent hostility or opposition
between
individuals or groups it's also
described as
inner striving unrest or imbalance often
with
physiological indication of emotion
it's also the act or action of
stretching
or the condition or degree of being
stretched
to stiffness and finally it's either of
two balancing forces
causing or tending to cause extension
of course the bridge would be in most
parts self-supporting
with a substantial structure but i felt
like
the symbolic gesture of the two
buildings holding up the bridge
even in some minor way added a powerful
narrative that i didn't really want to
compromise
and the motion of pulling and tension
in large part drove the design of the
individual buildings
as i went through multiple iterations
the two buildings are identical
and they torque as it goes up which
means that each floor plate
rotates at an angle providing unique
views
on each floor like views to the
mountains
views of the city on the other side of
the border
views to the building across the border
views to the animal crossing and we also
have views for the border control
maybe the possibility of a united korea
is long gone
maybe the two countries have drifted way
too
far apart that reunification is an
unrealistic proposition
our history is always a part of us
and if nothing else maybe it could at
least provide a place where people
can experience the beautiful
surroundings
and reflect on our collective memory and
ponder on what it means to have a shared
[Music]
identity
[Music]
[Music]
you